[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
tech talks I am your host hakan and
today we have a fasinating topic to dive
into artificial
intelligent in in this episode we will
explore the Incredible World of AI what
is this how is this changing or lies and
what the future holds whether you are an
AI Enthusiast or just curious about the
technology shaping your world you are in
for a treat so grab your headphones
settling and let's embark on this deep
dive into the realm of artificial intell
[Music]
intelligent let's take a closer look at
what AI truly is artificial intelligent
often abbreviated as AI is a
multiplicated field that involves the
development of computer systems
algorithms to perform task that when d
by humans require High
Intelligence these tasks Encompass
everything from understanding and
interpreting natural language to
recognizing patterns making decisions
and even creative problem solving AI
Foundation lies in machine learning a
subfield that allows AI systems to
improve their performance on tasks
through experience and data analysis
essentially it is a progress of teaching
a mission to learn adopt and make
predictions or decis decisions based on
its accumulated
knowledge classified into three primary
categories each with its own
characteristics and
implications first narrow AI also known
as weak AI is designed for specific task
or domains think of virtual assistants
like Siri or Google Assistant
recommendation algorithms on streaming
platforms or stelf driving cars these AI
systems excel in their PR defined
domains but like General human like
intelligence or strong represents the
Eliz goal of creating misss with human
like intelligence such as systems will
poses the ability of understand and
reason about about a wide range of
topics much like humans achieving a
general AI remains a theorical challenge
and there are ethical philosophical and
Technical hles to
overcome is the stuff of Science Fiction
often portrayed as AI that surprises
human intelligence and may even improve
and enchance
itself the concept raises profound
ethical and existential questions
including concerns about AI surprising
human
control AI in our daily lives changes or
you have already interacted with AI
today perhaps through voice assistance
like Siri or Google Assistant AI also
powers or social media feeds helping us
discover content we are interested in
recommendation algorithms on platforms
like Netflix or Amazon are excellent
example of
this
making strides in diiz daes and
personalizing tratment plans potentially
saving lives and in the automative
industry self driving cars use AI to
navigate the road safely and
efficiently immense benefits from
automating terious tasks to making
medical diagnosis is more
accurated however it also raises
concerns about Job displacement privacy
and
ethics can a human capabilities enabling
us to focus on creative and strategic
tasks while leing reparative work to
missions this could lead to significant
productivity
gains flip side the more we integrate AI
into our lives the more important it
becomes to addresses these issues
thoughtfully concerns about job
displacements are valid but history
shows that technology often creates more
jobs than it
eliminates the challenge is uring that
the new new jobs align with the skills
of the
workforce the critical ethical coars is
BS in AI since AI systems learn from
data they can inantly iner BSS presence
in data this BS can lead to discriminal
new outcomes which is significant
challenge we need to tle if you are not
careful AI can perate and even accessib
social
inequalities therefore ensuring that AI
systems are trained on the ver
representative data and subject to
reduce testing is essential to Mage this
B the future hold for AI we are seeing
AI applications expand rapidly from
health care and finance to
transportation and entertainment SII
continues to evolve we must invest in
research and ethical guidelines to
ensure it benefits soci as a
whole a field s in this infancy has the
potential to Revol tize AI by solving
complex problems at speeds unimaginable
today this combined with advances in
natural language progressing and
computer vision will lead to AI systems
that can better understand and interact
with
humans of AI on the job market is
another Hot Topic while AI can automate
repetive tasks it also creates new job
opportunities in AI development data
science and related fields continuous
learning and adaptability will be case
skills in the workforce of the
future expected to aent human
capabilities rather than replace them
think of AI is a powerful tool that
complement our abilities helping us make
more informed decisions and be more
productive as we WRA up today's episode
it is clear that AI is here to stay
shaping our word in profound ways while
it offers incredible potential it's also
demands responsibility it is our job to
ensure that AI is developed and use it
ethically benefiting everyone whether
you are excited about the possibilities
a presents or VAR of this impact to
future undt holds as a world where AI
plays a central role in how we live and
work Decay is two and Brands is
thoughtfully educate ourselves and activ
ly engage into conversation about ai's
future thank you for joining us on this
indepth exploration of the world of AI I
hope you have gained a deeper
understanding of this exciting field and
it is
implications until next time this is
hakan signing off from Tech talks stay
curious and exploring the ever evolving
world of
technology